so many felt the vaccine was presented
as a cure
that wouldn't require regular booster
shots
was that something you believed early on
did you always believe that many regular
shots would be required and maybe in a
bigger picture how many
do you think this would
for the fisa vaccine is it something you
see that's taking uh a booster shot
regularly like annually
yes in the beginning when we had the
first months of the vaccine people would
ask me do we need another one and i said
we don't know i was very clear about it
then around april may i started seeing
the first data and i made statements
that i think we will need a booster
around 8 to 12 months after the second
dose and then after that annually
vaccinations this is what i said
believe is the one of the most likely
scenarios
and it was based on the data that i had
but then delta came
and because i always making the
the caveat that with
absent and uvaria with everything we
know
with delta it was proven that we need
the booster to move to the three to the
six months and this is what
happened
and
i still said i think
the booster is a six months and then i
think it will be an annual
re-vaccination likely we have to monitor
to see the data but this is the likely
scenario
now we have omega and omegran says that
the
two doses might be challenging we don't
know exactly yet but three doses work
so clearly a lot of countries already
started moving now the third dose
not in six from six months to three
so that they will
reduce the period that people will not
be
protected with uh with
the third dose
i don't know with omicron if how long
this will last and frankly i don't know
if we will need a new vaccine
tailor-made to omicron based on
everything we know so far
we are monitoring and to know way more
in the weeks to come
if there is a need for a new vaccine we
will have it
and if there is a need for mass
production of this new vaccine
i can also feel very comfortable that we
will not lose any of our capacity that
we have developed right now we are
running
at 1 billion almost approximately
doses per quarter
four per year
and if we have to switch
and have half of that in the new half of
that in the old we will do still four
billion dollars so i think the world
should feel very very
comfortable that if there is a need we
will be ahead of the virus
you